[Music]
on this wednesday night alarming new
numbers in newfoundland and labrador
never has the province had so many
coveted 19 cases in one day
going so long was low case counts of
covid led to complacency
triggering calls to delay the election
newly released video of the u.s capitol
riot
they heard rioters say they were looking
for pence
in order to execute him the democrats
tried to prove former u.s
president trump incited an insurrection
the slow road to a future with electric
vehicles
why many canadians are reluctant to plug
in
and mission to mars did life exist there
in the past
what three countries hope to learn from
exploring the red planet
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin in newfoundland and labrador
and a cautionary tale
for the rest of the country new public
health restrictions are coming into
force there after a second day of a
spike
in covet 19 cases the biggest since the
start of the pandemic last spring
53 new cases were confirmed today 32
other cases are presumed positive there
are now a total of 110
active cases in newfoundland and
labrador into perspective one week ago
there were just
14 active cases the province's top
doctor warns this
is just the start we continue to see
high case counts
and we should expect this to continue as
contact tracing and testing continues
we are in for a rough period in the days
and weeks ahead what's happening in
newfoundland and labrador is a reminder
how quickly things can change
and how easily a low case count can
suddenly balloon
in tonight's top story ross lord reports
on what's fueling this surge
just days from a provincial election
long lineups for testing are a telltale
sign of a covet 19 outbreak that's
tripled in size
in each of the past two days i know
there's a great
deal of fear and worry about the latest
developments students at this high
school in mount pearl are among more
than a thousand people
forced into isolation i believe that
going so long with low case counts of
covid
led to complacency and we are now seeing
the repercussions kovit is colliding
with newfoundland and labrador's
provincial election
scheduled for saturday pc candidate
damien falett
has left the campaign trail to stay home
with his family
including his teenage son who has
coveted 19. i wish i didn't even be
concerned about anything except my
family right now and my friends
and lending support to the community
there are growing calls to delay the
election
until the outbreak subsides liberal
premier andrew fury a doctor turned
politician
was already criticized for calling the
election sooner than expected
now he insists it's not up to him to
decide if the vote goes ahead
i'm not a career politician you know
ambition is one thing but
primary focus is on public health and
safety
there have been no hospitalizations and
health officials insist they can ensure
the election is conducted
safely election planners are devising
drive-through voting
for people who are isolating the person
is
you know is not allowed to go inside the
building but they would certainly be
allowed inside of their car
and that as long as our people were
properly protected
if the outbreak keeps growing so might
pressure on health officials and
election planners
to reconsider ross lord global news
newfoundland and labrador isn't the only
place dealing with a surge
in north bay ontario public health
officials are trying to contain an
outbreak of one of the more contagious
new variants ontario now has confirmed
more than 230 cases of the variance
though
the true number is likely higher since
genomic sequencing is needed to confirm
them
outbreaks like the one in north bay
coupled with the slow vaccine rollout
and
questions about whether the variants can
evade vaccines
are causing a whole new set of concerns
abigail beeman
reports north bay ontario was doing well
in the pandemic
until now at least three cases of a
variant are presumed to be among the 19
people who tested positive in this
apartment building outbreak
which in turn closed a school i have a
daughter that was at the school
it's making me very anxious i've seen
what happened down in toronto
so i hope it don't happen here adding to
frustration
a slow vaccine rollout it sucks i got
severe lung troubles
and because i'm not in a nursing home
i gotta wait till the bottom of the line
they need to get their craft together
the conservatives called for an
emergency health committee meeting we're
looking for information
on what the federal government has been
doing to track
the variant spread as well as to
track the efficacy of current vaccine
candidates
against emerging variants already many
of the companies are updating their
vaccines to
accommodate for the variance of concern
a former federal health minister is now
part of ontario's planning
gearing up to track vaccine
effectiveness as we follow people and
line up the vaccine information with
other information around
what their lab results might be and
which type of
variant they might have acquired in
spite of being vaccinated
leaving the question of what going back
to so-called normal
really looks like even once uh
you know we're into mass vaccinations
there's going to be
a need to continue to be vigilant
against variance against
further further challenges as
economic challenges grow the economic
virus is just
almost as bad as the virus itself
this researcher's team tracks and
projects the impacts including the hit
to gdp
under different kinds of lockdown
scenarios over the
whole of 2021 is
an eight percent loss over over the
whole year
versus an 11 percent loss with the
on-again off-again kind of
policy losses in the tens of billions if
not hundreds
abigail beeman global news ottawa
indian prime minister narendra modi
spoke to prime minister
justin trudeau today and tweeted that he
reassured trudeau india would do its
best to facilitate supplies
of covet vaccines the serum institute of
india has a contract with astrazeneca to
supply 1 billion vaccine doses to a
number of countries
health canada is reviewing the
manufacturing processes at the facility
it has yet to approve the astrazeneca
vaccine
the world health organization is trying
to ease doubts about the efficacy of the
astrazeneca vaccine against the new
variants
the who says limited data means it is
too early to know for sure how the
variants will impact vaccines but they
believe
the astrazeneca shot should be given to
adults of all ages and will offer
some protection earlier this week south
africa paused its astrazeneca rollout
after a small trial suggested the shot
may not work as well against the new
variant
first detected there today south african
officials said they are considering
selling or swapping their astrazeneca
doses for a different vaccine
frontline workers in alberta will
receive one-time payments of 12-hundred
dollars from the provincial government
premier jason kenney says the money will
go to those who have put their lives at
risk
on the job during the pandemic there are
signs the public health
restrictions in alberta are working case
numbers have been dropping since hitting
a high in early december
but in some rural areas the numbers are
beginning to rise
there has been pushback against the
restrictions from some small businesses
faith groups and local politicians
heather urex west reports
for weeks the grace life church has
ignored public health restrictions
holding services outside edmonton with
as many as
300 people it's just one example of the
growing pushback against coveted
measures coming from rural alberta
resistance that could help explain why
covet infections are now spreading
faster there in the non-city environment
it seems to be higher than it is in the
city environments which is
quite the opposite of many other places
throughout the canada right now the r or
reproductive number measures how quickly
cases are going up or down
anything less than one means numbers are
falling
over the last three weeks alberta's
overall r number has risen
slightly but it hasn't been calgary and
edmonton driving that number up
areas outside the big cities have seen
their r values surge
and it has nearly reached the point
where cases will begin to rise
so we have to continue with these public
safety measures
and critically we have to be aware that
there is now viral variance in the
community
but people in smaller alberta centers
have been getting mixed messages from
government
last month when some restaurants opened
in defiance of public health orders
two small town mayors broke the rules to
show their support
and now two members of premier jason
kenny's caucus have joined a national
coalition
pushing back against lockdowns the
premier says
that's within their right we unlike some
other parties allow people to speak
their minds and represent
views of their constituents but this
expert warns the virus
doesn't play politics the word of a
politician is very powerful
and it's very dangerous because it in
one way you're opposing science
on the other way you're actually winking
at those who follow conspiracy theories
and say you know what
it's okay you know because the numbers
could soon paint a very different
picture
if rural alberta doesn't change course
heather urex west global news
calgary president trump
put a target on their backs and his
mob broke into the capitol to
hunt them down the impeachment trial of
former president donald trump has
released new video of what happened when
a mob of trump supporters stormed the
capitol the democrats are building a
case that trump spent months
building a fire before lighting the
match as they say on january 6.
as jackson proskow reports house
impeachment managers presented
a troubling play-by-play today of how it
all unfolded
the second man through the window is
wearing full
tactical body armor and is carrying a
baseball bat
in graphic detail never before seen
footage was presented at the impeachment
trial
showing how close the mob came to
carrying out a massacre
as the rioters reached the top of the
stairs
they were within 100 feet of where the
vice president was sheltering with his
family
senators were shown video of the enraged
mob threatening to kill the vice
president
and speaker nancy pelosi
in an attempt to overthrow american
democracy
because the truth is this attack never
would have happened
but for donald trump as democrats make
their case they've moved beyond the
traumatic events of january
6th the evidence shows clearly that this
mob was provoked over many months
by donald j trump they argue the
storming of the capital was rooted in
trump's persistent lies about a stolen
election
a campaign that spanned months and riled
up supporters at every turn
frankly we did win this election
the effort was blatant carried out in
plain sight
and democrats argue trump clearly told
his supporters where to be
and what to do on december 19
at 1 42 in the morning our
commander-in-chief
tweeted big protest in dc on january 6th
be there will be wild
will be wild by the time trump took to
the stage on january 6
democrats allege he knew exactly what
would happen next
because he assembled the mob he summoned
the mob
and he incited the mob in the days ahead
trump's defense is likely to focus
strictly on the events of the sixth
arguing the riots were pre-planned as
democrats allege
and therefore could not have been
incited by trump in that instance
it may be hard to separate that from the
jarring images of the day
showing a mob that clearly believed it
was acting on orders
from one man alone the number of
reporters inside the senate chamber is
limited because of the pandemic but we
know from those in the room that the day
started with some senators putting their
feet up on their desks and doodling
during the impeachment trial
it ended with everyone in the room
absolutely gripped by that harrowing new
video footage
donna all right jackson proskow in
washington thank you
zero emissions but plenty of hesitation
coming up why many canadians are
reluctant to buy
an electric vehicle
prime minister justin trudeau is
planning to fund nearly 15 billion
dollars in public transportation
projects
across the country these investments
will support major
public transit projects like subway
extensions
help electrify electrify fleets
with zero emission vehicles they will
also be used to meet the growing demand
for walkways
and paths for cycling and help rural and
remote communities
the prime minister says the money will
be spread out over eight years and will
be a stable source of funding so cities
can plan for long-term needs
most of the money though won't start
flowing until 2026.
electric vehicles are gaining traction
in canada but not fast enough to meet
the federal government's own targets
it aims to have 10 percent of all light
duty vehicle sales
be electric by 2025 and 100 percent
by 2040. through access to information
requests our chief political
correspondent david aiken has obtained
internal government polling that sheds
some light on
what's holding back canadians from
buying more electric vehicles
david the federal government has had
incentive programs to get canadians into
both electric
and hybrid vehicles since stephen harper
was prime minister but
so far at least those programs are not
showing the success that everyone wants
just 2.6 percent of canadians own a
plug-in electric vehicle
only 3.6 on a hybrid most canadians 80
still own good old-fashioned gas or
diesel cars
this data is from an internal government
poll done in late november for the prime
minister's department the privy council
office
so what's been holding consumers back
from buying an electric vehicle
answer they're just too expensive that
was the number one reason cited by 43
percent
of those surveyed by the pco lack of
infrastructure
charging stations and the lake was cited
by 15 percent
and concerns about reliability was an
issue for 10 percent
now the trudeau government has been
offering subsidies of up to five
thousand dollars for those who buy a
zero emission electric vehicle
and it's in the midst of a five-year 130
million dollar program
to build more charging stations across
the country
the pco poll suggests the government
could ramp that
up a majority of voters in every
province including alberta
support the idea of federal cash being
used to help get consumers
into electric vehicles just over 71
percent
nationally like the idea including 54
percent of albertans
well 78 percent of quebecers and
almost as many in ontario and bc
gave the idea a thumbs up and so with
such strong support
in the election battleground provinces
of ontario and quebec and british
columbia
the pco and by extension the prime
minister's office
knows they've got a vote winner right
here and so
you should expect to see federal cash
for
electric vehicles front and center in
this year's
spring budget donna okay david aiken in
ottawa thank you
sister survivor ahead what an elderly
nun in france is celebrating
the family of a prominent women's rights
activist who has ties to canada
says she has been released from a prison
in saudi arabia after nearly three years
lujan al-hatlul was granted probation by
a judge in riyadh today
and released to her family al-hathlul
was arrested in 2018 she was locked up
for things canadians consider basic
human rights such as
driving a car and campaigning against
female oppression
al hathalul's family says she was
subjected to electric
shock in prison and sexually harassed
her probation prohibits her from talking
about her time behind bars and she can't
leave saudi arabia for five years
she is a graduate of the university of
british columbia
a nun in france has something big to
celebrate
not only did she survive covet 19 she
turns
117 tomorrow sister andre
who is europe's oldest person was among
81 people in her nursing home to get
covid19
she was lucky to have no symptoms aside
from sleeping more than usual
sister andre is now blind and uses a
wheelchair and she has lived through a
lot
including the 1918 flu pandemic and both
world wars
she says she plans to celebrate her
birthday with a feast
and a glass of champagne cheers to that
space jam next what's fueling heavy
traffic around the red planet
you could call it mars madness for the
first time three spacecraft from three
different nations will be exploring the
red planet at the
same time missions from china and the
united arab emirates are orbiting mars
now
and nasa's mars rover is scheduled to
land next week
eric sorenson explains what they're
hoping to teach us about earth's
neighbor
one and liftoff two
three spacecraft blasted off from mars
last year
china's tian wen one has just arrived
slowing into its orbit around mars
a highly ambitious somewhat secretive
mission is the first to include an
orbiter a lander and a rover china is
the sixth country to reach martian orbit
the fifth arrived yesterday the hope
spacecraft from the united arab emirates
will not land
but will circle to study the atmosphere
and climate
it's an historic breakthrough for the
arab world that looks to diversify from
its oil economy
for our science community this is an a a
large leap for them they today have
a mission around another planet
collecting data for the very first time
the two missions hope and tien when one
will be joined next week by a third
nasa's perseverance it's a little like
rush hour to mars
all three spacecraft left earth last
july it's a rare opportunity that comes
around only once every 26 months when
the earth and mars are relatively close
to each other
and the three spacecraft can make the
500 million kilometer journey
to catch up to the martian orbit in just
seven months
as the hope spacecraft remains in orbit
the chinese will send down their lander
this spring
then comes perseverance it arrives in
one week
and it will land almost immediately in
jezreel crater
here because jezreel was a real lake
more than three billion years ago
fed by a river and surrounded by an
atmosphere that may have supported life
the ultimate discovery did life exist
there in the past does life exist there
now and could life including us
exist there in the future and so a lot
of the missions
have been piecing together insights
perseverance is the first in a series of
missions by nasa
that will drill into the martian surface
for rock samples that will be sealed and
stored
then picked up by future missions and
returned to earth 10 years from now
it only gets more exciting from here
space agencies on earth are planning to
send humans out to explore
first a return to the moon in this
decade and then
to mars in the 2030s our first
interplanetary travel
is just around the corner eric sorensen
global news
toronto we couldn't leave you tonight
without an update on the kitten
practicing law on zoom in case you
haven't seen it or maybe you just need
another laugh
here it is mr ponton i believe you have
a
filter turned on in the video settings
uh you might want to uh uh
we're trying to can you hear me judge
uh i'm prepared to go forward with it
that's i'm here live that's not i'm not
a cat
the eyes make it so good the kitten is
actually texas lawyer
rod ponton he says his assistant's
daughter had been using the computer
before him and he couldn't figure out
how to get rid of that pesky cat filter
he is happy though it's making people
laugh
i was having lunch after that uh hearing
and
i was wondering why my phone was blowing
up with calls from around the country
and around the world
uh i didn't know if i was in trouble or
what was going on but
i finally figured it out uh you know
i i i got as big a laugh out of it as
everybody else
that is global national for this
wednesday i'm donna friesen
i've been told no more cat filters from
me but we do have
this gorgeous shot of the northern
lights near stetler alberta
there are beautiful spots all over
canada please email
your canada to viewers at
globalnational.com
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow
take care of yourselves bye-bye